everything was happening in technology
in us now China are running and they are
really competing with us entrepreneur to
being the best
so for European entrepreneur is very
important to be connected with in each
other and try to collaborate because the
real competition now is not foreign
talent the preneur to go in Spain or in
Germany the real competition is on a
Chinese entrepreneur with 10 times more
the money and investment size but
compete with you with a bigger scale in
the first phases undivided after 28
years old from Italy co-founder and CEO
of Tallinn Garden Tallinn garden is the
biggest European network of co-working
space and indication platform for
helping and empower tech innovators
around Europe I'm coming from an
entrepreneurial family my father was
founded some different restaurants
around my hometown and my mother
organizing events and probably growing
up in a restaurant really give me what
does it mean about hospitality what is
the meaning of it and so in Tallinn
garden what we try is not only to create
a co-working but to really great place
where people feel at home where we can
really feel and grow between connecting
with each other and stay well all the
Tallinn garden people are from tech
industry but there are start uppers
there are freelancer very investors
there are all the technical system we
are trying to create a place where all
the ecosystem can meet can connect
between each other and try to stay
together innovation is not growing
anymore
only in San Francisco all in London the
idea is innovators are everywhere and we
have to try to support them to empower
them and connect in a global family
where we can really support and grow all
over the world Hostelling garden we try
exactly to do this creating physical
campus with aggragate the best people
giving them all the tools that they need
to grow at European scale
[Music]